andris machetes it chapter 2 wraps up
the events of the 2017 box office smash
it at nearly three hours long it
provides plenty of scares and one
hilarious performance from Bill Hader
but did you spot these references to
other Stephen King adaptations or
callbacks to the first film and yes
spoilers are coming the movie is set in
2016
27 years after the events of the first
film the book it by Stephen King is set
in 1958 and 1985 so there was some
deviation from the original novel the
movie opens with the homophobic attack
on Adrian this is featured in the novel
but not in the 1990 miniseries King
based the event on the real-life 1984
murder of Charlie Howard a gay man
attacked and thrown for the State Street
bridge in Bangor Maine early in the film
were introduced to the now adult Bill
Denver on the set of the adaptation of
his book attic room the director of
attic room its Peter Bogdanovich the
director of The Last Picture Show a king
connection the author makes repeated
references to the last picture show in
his novel Lisa's story as character
Scott London frequently watches the film
Phil also talks about sliding under the
stage door like Indiana Jones builds
Beverly look-alike wife in this scene is
played by Jessica Chastain's real-life
BFF Jess wit slur when now adult beverly
is reunited with Mike and Ben we can see
the scars on her arm from her abusive
husband Tom Rogen
Beverly goes to visit her childhood home
it's inhabited by mrs. Kirsch as the
name on the door changes briefly from
Bosch to Kirsch king named the character
mrs. Kirsch after Irvin Kershner the
director of The Empire Strikes Back the
1980 movie was shot in the same studio
at the same time as The Shining
and King even visited the set something
not really featured in the 2017 film its
Beverly's nightmares about Hansel and
Gretel
mrs. Kirsch is reminiscent of the witch
in the Germanic folk story making a
comment about the hot oven and welcoming
Beverly inside 40 just like the children
in the fairy tale are welcomed in for
sweets there are a few Pennywise clues
before mrs. Kirsch transforms into the
villain the actress who plays mrs.
Kirsch Jane Gregson is no stranger to
King's work having starred in ABC's
storm at the century in 1999 we see shop
exteriors of the town of Derry some of
which are named after real-life places
in Port Hope Ontario where the movie was
filmed there is a real-life Queenie's
Bake Shop fun fact
Queeny was also the name of king's
childhood dog inside dairies secure
institution a cartoon is playing on the
TV this cartoon is Tom and Jerry the
truth hurts depicting a steak fully into
a sewer the steak floats away just like
Georgie's boat in it the movie includes
lots of flashbacks and locations to
character saw decades ago so there are a
lot of 80s references throughout
the losers returned to their underground
Clubhouse in a flashback scene we get a
few eighties references cameos 1986 hit
word up it's playing there's a poster
for the 1987 movie The Lost Boys and one
of Michael J Fox from his 1987 cover of
Rolling Stone
Ritchie revisits the arcade where he had
played Street Fighter the classic 1980s
game on the wall behind him is a poster
for 1998 you've got mail this the second
time meg Ryan pops up in a movie as you
might recall in the opening scenes
Adrienne shouts to the bullies meg Ryan
called she wants her wig back Ben hides
in a locker from Pennywise behind him on
the locker wall we see a poster of danny
from New Kids on the Block here's where
we also get a direct quote from the 1990
miniseries the turtle from the books
pops up in several places in the movie
there's a drawing of a turtle on the
desk in Ben's classroom a statue of one
outside Ben's house and also an
engraving of one on the door to
Pennywise aschler King makes a cameo in
the movie much like he has done in other
adaptations of his work this time he's
an antiques dealer wearing a Neil Young
t-shirt an old license plate near the
counter is the CQB two-for-one license
on the 1958 Plymouth Fury in 1983's
Christine in the it novel Henry Bowers
escapes from the asylum in a cherry red
1958 Plymouth Fury King makes a joke at
his own expense bill asks Kings
character if he wants him to sign the
book that he's reading to which King
replies no as the ending was bad the
book's cover has all the visual
hallmarks of a king novel this parallel
between criticisms of Kings work and
Bill's books having bad endings crops up
a few times in the movie the store
second hand rose it's the same from the
novel and 1994 insomnia
secondhand rose second-hand clothes
speaking of cameos look out for undress
machete as a customer in the drugstore
when Eddie goes to pick up his
prescription Eddie's wife miracast Brack
is played by the same actress who played
his mother
Sonya guess he never really escaped his
mom after all one of adult bends
boardroom colleagues is none other than
Brandon crane who played the kid Ben in
the 1990 miniseries in a scene where
bill runs through a fairground fun house
the swinging clown see run pass a
dressed up just like Tim Curry's 1990
version of penny wise as the gang
battles penny wise he turns into a
monster reminiscent at the spider lect
alien in 1982 the thing this time it's
young Stanley's head with a rekted legs
growing out of it
this is accompanied by a quote from the
thing when Beverly struggles for air in
the blood-soaked toilet cubicle a
variety of faces try to edge through the
door one of them says here's Johnny in
reference to the shining another 1980s
movie 1989 Nightmare on Elm Street 5 is
playing in the movie theater in the
closing shots in it chapter 2 the defeat
of penny wise it's almost like a late
series Freddy Krueger movie surreal and
CGI heavy Phil receives a phone call
from Mike at the end of the movie
in these scenes he's reading a copy of a
history of old dairy by Branson Budinger
you may recall this book from the first
movie as a one Ben reads and dairy
library in fact the room bill is in
looks quite similar to the office in the
final scene of Stand By Me where Richard
Dreyfuss as the writer types the movies
final scenes into his computer did you
spot anything else comment below
[Music]